Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Es geht schon ein bisschen besser als.
Ja, das wird eine heiße Sendung hier draußen äh brüht es auch schon ganz ordentlich hier. Der Sommer wird ja mittlerweile seinen Namen äh gerecht, so ist auch die Meterebene schon erhitzt bis zum Getner
und wir haben auch ein paar ganz heiße Themen, ja, endlich auch mal wieder was über Porno. Ja, das äh,
Ist auch einfach mal gut für die Quote so, ja. Immer nur so Politik und alles Scheiße und so, da muss man schon auch nochmal ein bisschen, ne, also.
Extreme Pornografie.
Andy. Ja, genau. So sieht's nämlich aus, Linus. Ja.
Haben wir. Gibt's im Internet.
Das habe ich auch gehört.
Bald allerdings nicht mehr.
Genau, kommen wir zum Thema äh zum ersten Thema äh ja Britannien, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich diesem Land überhaupt noch sagen soll,
Ja, es ist ja eher auch so,
wie sage ich's jetzt? Das ist mal nicht wieder alles falsch verstanden. Aber so, ich weiß nicht, die Briten sind auch irgendwie in gewisser Hinsicht so dermaßen auf diesem Owelian,
quasi also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Nachtbuch.
Und äh lassen auch irgendwie nichts aus,
Und nachdem wir uns jetzt hier in den letzten Wochen schon ausreichend äh empört haben über Tempora und sagen wir mal generell auch so dieses äh diese fünfer Konstellation der ähm englischsprechenden Staaten,
Ähm ja, kommt jetzt hier gleich das nächste Ding und was also in Deutschland überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat, in Britannien ist das jetzt, glaube ich, auch schon live, oder?
Nee, nee, äh Sie haben das, Sie haben das jetzt in mehreren,
Phasen. Also David Cameron hat sich jetzt irgendwie, ich glaube, am Montag war das, hat er sich hingestellt und er hat gesagt, dass er jetzt endlich mal, ne, Jugendschutz und mit dieser ganzen Pornografie im Internet, das kann ja so nicht weitergehen. Und er hat da jetzt einfach in mehreren,
In mehreren Phasen.
Die Jugend wird ja verschmutzt.
Die Jugend wird versaut, ja? Und da äh das Problem ist eben, wenn man das irgendwie äh wenn man dann die ganze Schweinereien im Netz auf dem,
Mit mit Pornofiltern auf dem Computer filtern möchte, dann besteht ja die Gefahr, dass die Kinder diese Filter irgendwie wieder deaktivieren, ja.
Und deswegen hat er jetzt gesagt, okay, er möchte ähm auf auf mehrere Weisen gegen die Pornografie im Internet vorgehen. Erstens.
Extreme Pornographie wird illegal, ja?
Also der Besitz extremer Pornographie wird illegalisiert. Extreme Pornographie, darunter fällt so etwas wie zum Beispiel bei sich Vergewaltigungs oder Fesselspiele
ja? Also es ist nicht, dass es dass es irgendwie, sagen wir mal, dieser Gorm wäre oder wie das heißt, wo es
Tatsächliche dann äh äh Dokumentationen von, heißt das nicht, Gore, also wie Elgor,
Heißt das nicht so? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich bin da,
go, Spam, weiß ich nur, dass das ein äh Begriff ist. Das habe ich nämlich schon mal bekommen.
Na, aber okay. Äh vielleicht habe ich auch gar kein, also man sieht, ich habe gar keine Ahnung davon. Ist das so, ne?
Graphic Violence. Ist das so, ne? Ja, okay,
Graphic war, okay, also sozusagen so, wenn's sehr realistisch ist, das heißt das, okay, verstehe.
Filmische Körperdarstellung, ja, ja genau. Also äh extreme Pornografie, sagen wir mal, Vergewaltigungs äh also geschauspielerte,
dokumentierte Vergewaltigungen sind dann eben äh also das sowieso etwas wird illegalisiert dann in den USA. Grundsätzlich schon mal, darf nicht mit äh darf nicht besessen werden,
Äh äh ja genau in UK, Entschuldigung. Ähm und außerdem möchte er natürlich gegen ähm.
Gegen äh äh Pädophile vorgehen. Und ähm da möchte er zum Beispiel,
Äh so eine, also so eine Pornographie, Datenbank dann haben. Auch das eine Idee, die in Deutschland auch schon mal diskutiert wurde oder ich glaube, da,
sogar irgendwie eine, wo sie quasi dann die ah ja genau, es gibt äh eine,
Kinderpornografie, beziehungsweise dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch, Datei, Datenbank, in der dann die Datei-Hashes gesammelt werden.
Das erleichtert dann eben die automatische Suche auf Festplatten. Ja, das heißt man, wenn da irgendwie paar tausend Bilder drauf sind, muss man sich die nicht alle anschauen, sondern diejenigen, die bekannt sind, findet man dann halt auch automatisch nicht schnell
alle Dateien herrschen muss, aber automatisch. Und der,
der äh warum das eigentlich auch so gut funktioniert bei dokumentiertem Kindesmissbrauch. Kleiner Hinweis ist, dass es davon relativ wenig gibt
Das heißt, die Anzahl der Bilder ist äh relativ begrenzt. Ja, also in dieser Datenbank ist äh ist halt eine bestimmte Anzahl von,
drin und das sind auch Dateien, die man dann immer wieder bei den äh bei den Menschen findet, weil es davon eben einfach nicht viel gibt. In in diesem Millionengeschäft, wir wissen das ja Millionen.
Ja ja.
Das äh funktioniert ja anscheinend hauptsächlich über Verknappung, ja. Äh.
So ähm dafür soll's also sein, eine Datenbank geben,
Und er möchte dann zum Beispiel auch gemeldet haben, wenn äh bestimmte Suchanfragen getätigt werden,
die von äh Pädophilen getätigt werden. Also er hatte da in in seiner Rede dieses Beispiel, wenn jemand eingibt, Teen Sex,
dann sollte doch bitte Google sagen,
A, meinst du Teen Sex Education und möchtest etwas über die Aufklärung von Jugendlichen lernen? So, du möchtest aber doch wohl nicht ähm hier, ne,
irgendwie, ne? Und sowas, also da möchte er einerseits, möchte er das gemeldet haben, wenn Leute so etwas suchen und andererseits möchte er, dass Google solche Anfragen.
Eben entweder in der eben genannten Weise bereinigt, beziehungsweise wenn sie ganz äh explizit sind, ähm nicht beantwortet.
Also er möchte gerne, dass äh das äh Google und andere Suchmaschinen freiwillig äh bestimmte Suchanfragen einfach nicht beantworten.
Und dazu gibt er den Suchmaschinen ähm Zeit bis Ende der ähm ich glaube, er hatte so gesagt, bis Ende des Jahres, ja? Und sagt, ähm ihr habt hier ähm.
Ähm sagt also, ihr könnt jede jedes technische Problem löst ihr, ihr habt irgendwie die die Welt,
verkatert. Ihr habt äh äh die Straßen fotografiert. Jetzt könnt ihr auch mal irgendwie äh die Schweinebilder aus dem Internet äh raus äh oder aus euren Suchergebnissen rausfiltern.
Anderen nicht so schwer sein.
Ja? Ähm ihr habt ihr habt unglaubliche Algorithmen gebaut. So und jetzt äh,
ihr habt offensichtlich die großartigsten hier, ne. Ich verlasse mich darauf, dass ihr das hinbekommt. Solltet ihr das nicht äh hinbekommen, eurer äh Verantwortung,
gegenüber der Gesellschaft gerecht zu werden, dann äh wird's da relativ schnell legislative Maßnahmen,
geben, die haben wir schon in der Schublade, aber bis aufs erste möchte erstmal, dass sie das.
Videos mit Google-Mitarbeitern.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, äh was er da machen möchte. Viel spannender ist aber, das sind jetzt erstmal nur so die äh allgemeiner Kram. Dann sagt er, ja und außerdem werden jetzt alle Internetanschlüsse,
Dies in UK gibt und auch alle offenen Wifis, also überall, wo irgendjemand ins Internet geht,
das wird jetzt gefiltert und zwar mit Jugendschutzfiltern.
Von wem?
Und da wird die Pornografie gesperrt. Eben anhand dieser zentralen Datenbank, in der die gesamte Pornografie des Internets gesammelt werden soll, so ungefähr.
Also nicht die Porno, ja, also ich finde das äh ja gut, aber auf der einen Seite reden wir hier von Kipo, ja.
Pornographie, ganz klar Pornographie. Weil,
Ist ja keine Zensur. Jetzt kommt der spannende Teil. Du kannst, wenn du quasi deinen Internetanschluss kaufst, ähm kannst du ja das Häkchen machen, dass du den Diffeld-Porno-Filter bitte nicht haben möchtest.
Kann man.
Abbestellen, wenn du einfach nur weiterklickst,
wobei ich das auch schon witzig finde, wenn also weiterklicken beim Internetanschluss bestellt. Ich weiß es, also ich bestelle mein, habe meinen Internetanschluss über ich glaube über Telefon oder Briefwahl bestellt, weil ähm,
nicht klicken. Aber wie auch immer. Also wenn du wenn du weiterklickst ja ähm also dass Dead ist, wenn du alles nur ausfüllst, ja ich will Internet und nicht noch irgendwo im Kleingedruckten ein Häkchen setzt,
Dann hast du automatisch einen Filter da drin. Und das wird dadurch begründet, damit eben da der ja dann beim Providersitz dieser Filter, können die Kinder und Jugendlichen denen ja nicht umgehen. Und wer ein Schmutzfink ist,
ein verachtenswertes Mitglied der Gesellschaft und hier,
die den Leuten beim Schaukeln zugucken möchte im Internet. Der kann ja dann beim beim Anschluss kaufen dieses Häkchen setzen,
und seinen Ausweis zeigen und in der Kundendatenbank als äh als Schmutzfink.
Als Schweinepriester.
Als Schwein. Schmutzfink,
So, so macht man das, ja? Wunderbar. Das Problem hat der gute Mann gelöst. Bis Ende 2013 wird diese Regelung dann für alle Neukunden gelten,
dass du dieses Häkchen hast und bis Ende 2014 wird es dann für alle umgesetzt werden. Das heißt, sie kriegen dann irgendwie ihre AGB-Änderung und so, ne? Und können dann äh können dann sich können dann bei ihrem Provider anrufen und sagen, bitte, ich möchte weiter hier.
Das Vereinigte Königreich von Schmutzfinken und Schweinepries.
Ich find's spannend. Also das Krasse ist halt.
Aber ich frage mich gerade drüber die ganze Zeit, was bitte wollen sie da an welcher Stelle, wo wie jetzt filtern, also ich meine, was in HTTP Verbindungen oder was, also.
Wir kennen ja die, also da hat er sich jetzt,
Zu dem technischen Details hat er sich da gar nicht besonders geäußert. Aber wir kennen ja die die Möglichkeiten, die jetzt im Provider hätte. Na, er könnte DNS-Sperren machen,
er könnte natürlich auch IP-Bereiche IP-Adressen sperren. Natürlich bei dem bei im Falle der IP-Adressen mit entsprechenden Kollateralschäden.
Auch vielleicht bei den DNS schon.
Zentrale Datenbank, Thema erledigt.
So einfach.
So, jetzt gibt's natürlich äh für unsere Briten ähm,
mehrere Möglichkeiten, das zu umgehen. Und äh ne, das Einfachste ist dann irgendwie so ein Proxiserver ähm oder ein VPN, SSL sollte das unter Umständen auch schon umgehen.
Na gut, keine IP sperren.
Na ja, wenn du, sagen wir mal, du, du äh wenn du,
Wenn sie nicht IPs sperren, sondern nur DNS, dann könntest du das mit SSL umgehen, weil du dann davon ausgehen müsstest, es gibt ein Share-Host und solange du die DNS-Anfrage irgendwo anders herholst,
kannst ja mit der IP sprechen, weil da könnt ihr auch was anderes sein. Und erst im SSL.
Also erstmal auf einen anderen DNS-Server umstellen, der so nicht äh gefiltert ist.
Genau, also es gibt ja klar, also diese SSL ist eher so ein theoretisches Konzept, ja. Das wird am EWC am Ende nicht durchsetzen. Also, was sich durchsetzen wird, wer sind dann wahrscheinlich VPNs?
Oder eben äh in der sehr doch schon eher äh konservativen, britischen Gesellschaft, dass die Leute hingehen und sagen, ja äh hier ich bin, ich möchte gerne hier Schmuddelbilder gucken. Das kannst du natürlich in der, also,
die hat die die Schraube, die da angezogen wird, ist natürlich ganz klar. Wenn er sagen würde, das Ding ist, dieses Häkchen ist bei Defold nicht gesetzt. Wir schaffen nur die Möglichkeit für euch, liebe äh liebe äh Königsreichs Bürger, Königreichsbürger,
Wie nennt man das Untertanen? So, liebe Untertanen, ähm,
ihr könnt die Regierung hat einen neuen Dienst für euch, ihr könnt dieses Häkchen bei euch setzen. Ist das nicht was Feines? Ja?
Dann würden, sagen wir mal, vielleicht fünf bis acht Prozent das Häkchen setzen. Diejenigen, die irgendwie ihre Kinder da schützen wollen, vielleicht sind's auch sogar, würden sie bis zu 20 Prozent sein, mehr aber nicht.
Jetzt ist zu bezweifeln, ob 20 Prozent das Häkchen setzen, dass sie das nicht wollen. Das ist ja immer genau einfach nur die die politische Dimension des die Falls,
von dem keiner abweichen möchte. Und ähm ja, so sieht's ja jetzt also aus.
Ist dir das jetzt alles schon beschlossen und eingetütet und final und durch oder äh regt sich da noch irgendeinen Widerstand bei irgendjemand?
Er hat das jetzt erstmal angekündigt, es äh.
Ich glaube es, ich ich weiß nicht genau, wie, also es ist bis jetzt noch ein Vorhaben. Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das,
noch irgendwie durchs Parlament oder über den Tisch der Queen muss. Ich kenne aber den genauen Gesetzgebungsprozess in ähm,
und die Stärken der ähm die Stärken der Koalition oder was in UK gerade nicht. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, wie realistisch das ist, dass da nochmal irgendwas dran geändert wird. Mein Verständnis ist aber, dass dass der Cameron da doch eine
nennenswerte Mehrheit hat, sodass wenn ihr das ankündigt, dass im Zweifel auch so kommen wird.
Naja, das wollen wir mal sehen, ne. Ja, also der Kampf gegen äh die Krankheit des Pornos, ich weiß gar nicht, irgendwie komme ich mir so ein bisschen vor, wie so im im mittleren äh äh Westen der USA, ja, also.
Pornographie so als ewiger Feind und meine wie erfolgreich das äh sein wird, das werden wir dann sehen.
Habe mir das nicht ähm vorstellen, dass es so problemlos ähm.
Funktionieren wird, ja? Also vielleicht wird es politisch durchgehen, ob das dann eben auch äh technisch funktioniert, weil ich meine, wir hatten in der ganzen Zensursula-Debatte,
ja schon diese ganze Diskussion und vielleicht für die Leute, die unseren Lacher vorhin auch nicht verstanden haben so mit diesem Millionengeschäft, ja, also,
Das war ja so eine Argumentation von Ursula, von der Leyen, in dieser permanenten
einen permanenten Hatz reden, die sie da immer wieder gestartet hat, um ihr Projekt zu verteidigen, ja, das sich ja hier um ein Millionengeschäft äh handeln würde.
Es war das wie weit.
Von ist es davon ist nichts bekannt, ja? Also es gibt.
Es ist einfach nichts mehr vom Bekannten.
Ja und äh es viel mehr ist auch davon auszugehen, dass es alles andere als das ist,
Das ist natürlich ein Problem, aber ist halt ein Problem auf einem anderen Level und schon gar nicht eins, was eben zu äh umfangreicher Zensur führen sollte, außer man ist natürlich in Britannien und ähm das meinte ich halt auch eingangs,
Was ich wirklich hochgradig beklagenswert finde, ist diese stursche Hinnahme von all diesen,
gesellschaftszerstörenden Maßnahmen in Britannien, das ist schon wirklich krass,
gibt's auch irgendwie so recht keinen Widerstand. Habe ich so den Eindruck, oder?
Keine Ahnung. Ähm nochmal zur Betonung, es geht hier nicht. Also er hat natürlich einen Fokus auf äh auf äh Kinder und und diese extreme, ja? Ähm,
Aber er sagt ganz klar, nö, na, na, na.
Ja, vor allem, wer soll denn das bewerten, was jetzt irgendwie familienfreundlich ist oder nicht familienfreundlich. Ich meine, man kann schon lange darüber diskutieren, ob das Sperren von Pornoinhalten familienfreundlich ist. Ähm ja.
Also Kinder äh Kinderpornografie natürlich hier auch der Fokus, aber darauf nicht beschränkt.
So lese ich das hier nochmal nach und so habe ich auch seine äh Rede verstanden. Ähm
Natürlich kann er jetzt nicht die komplette Pornografie aus dem Internet verscheuchen, weil er muss irgendwie auch noch damit leben, dass zum Beispiel ja regelmäßig da,
äh oben ohne Frauen haben, ja, das heißt, da wird's nochmal irgendwie eine
äh äh wird's nochmal irgendwie eine Abstufung geben, ab wann dann Pornographie Pornographie ist oder was auch immer oder wo die Grenze zwischen Erotik und Pornografie äh äh genannt wird. Aber ähm,
Ja, wir sehen, wohin das hier führt. Nochmal so ganz kurz für diejenigen Hörer und Hörerinnen, der es vielleicht damals die die Zensursolla-Debatte nicht mitbekommen haben. Was sich da also zeigte, ist, dass dieser ähm,
Also da der Besitz von äh,
dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch ja selbstverständlich Illegales in Deutschland entgegen dem, was da irgendwie behauptet wurde, auch in jedem anderen Land der Welt illegal ist. Es gibt, glaube ich, irgendwie ein Land der Welt, was aus Versehen kein Gesetz dagegen hat
sie ein Gesetz gegen gegenüberhaupt gegen Sex haben so ungefähr. So hatte ich das in Erinnerung. Was dieser Markt.
Da gibt's keinen Markt, das sind äh ist eine kleine Gruppe oder eine eine geringe Anzahl von Menschen mit äh diesen Neigungen, die teilweise auch sehr stark darunter
natürlich leiden, weil sie wissen, dass das äh durchaus ein Problem ist,
ja, dass diese Form der Sexualität in der äh also in dieser Gesellschaft, in dieser Zeit absolut geächtet wird, ähm
natürlich schwierigen empfindlichen Gefängnisstrafen verbunden ist, die dann eben äh quasi so eine Art,
Selbstmedikation mit mit dieser äh mit dieser mit diesen Dokumentationen betreiben. Und gleichzeitig,
aufgrund ihrer Illegalität eben sehr klar äh agieren, ja, die dann eben irgendwelchen das sind dann immer diese Tauschringe,
die die alle drei Jahre mal irgendwo hochgenommen werden, wo 20 Mann dann in irgendein geheimen Server irgendwie gegenseitig diese Bildchen tauschen, die sie irgendwoher hatten,
so ungefähr muss man sich diesen Millionenmarkt vorstellen. Ähm.
Ich bin ja äh sehr, sehr bekannt, dass ich äh Psychologe bin und entsprechend auch ähm
ein sehr starkes Mitgefühl mit dem Leidensdruck dieser Menschen habe.
Ja? Der sich natürlich nicht darin äh entladen kann, darf oder sollte, dass sie diese Handlung selber verüben, aber man sollte sich schon überlegen, dass diese Menschen unter also wirklich unter einem sehr starken Leidenshof stehen und ähm,
ja, jede Hilfe in die ihnen irgendwie die Welt bieten kann, äh benötigen,
um irgendwie mit dieser Situation in die ihr Geist oder ihr Körper sie da gebracht hat irgendwie klar zu kommen,
Und das ist jetzt sicherlich nicht äh der ein ein adäquater Schritt, der dann in England geplant ist.
Gut, wir marschieren ein paar Meter weiter. Genau. Nach Schweden, da ist ja auch nicht unbedingt immer alles ähm in Ordnung.
Na ja, in Schweden, ich halte ja eigentlich, ich finde ja Schweden eigentlich na ja gut, ist nicht immer alles in Ordnung, stimmt. Also.
Nicht immer alles in Ordnung.
Es gab schon, ich hatte das vor ein paar Wochen schon in den äh vorgesehen für eine Sendung, die damals zu lang war. Ähm und zwar hatte hatten Anfang Juli Visa und Mastercard irgendwie Richtlinien an Online-Zahlungsdienstleister,
rausgegeben, gesagt, diese sind dringend und haben gesagt, ihr dürft nicht mehr,
dafür sorgen, dass der Anbieter Geld bekommt,
Also mit anderen Worten, Finanzblockade, genau wie bei Wikileaks mit Mastercard oder VISA, kann nicht mehr bezahlt werden. So, was ist ein Predator?
Ist ein VPN Dienstleister, wo man halt äh so Tunnel ins freie Netz sich äh holen kann, aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
Dahinter steckt mal wieder,
der tausend, ja, auch schon bekannt von und so weiter und jetzt ist er ja auch schon wieder mit dem nächsten Projekt äh also für jemanden, der verurteilt ist und eigentlich jetzt mal in den Knast gehen
sollte, also nicht, dass ich der Meinung bin, der sollte, aber irgendwie, ja, es gibt da sozusagen eine Verurteilung und äh,
Bin immer wieder überrascht, mit welchen Winkellzügen er es schafft, äh das irgendwie ewig äh herauszuzögern und äh ein neues Projekt nach dem anderen startet.
Ja und da weiterhin positives äh dieser Welt äh zu verleihen weiß, ja?
Einfach fleißig ist und äh so weiter und auch immer wieder mit mit pfiffigen Ideen äh und technischen Lösungen kommen. So, IP Radit, äh Data oder I-Preda oder wie man das auch immer äh.
Predator, weil es nämlich äh sich auf die äh IPred damals äh intellectional propoty, ähm Rights in Forcement Directive.
Ja, man könnte natürlich auch sagen, der Witz, mit ich, der Predator, ist natürlich auch ganz äh lustig. Also, wie auch immer, äh dieser Dienst auf jeden Fall steht jetzt quasi genauso unter Beschuss wie zuletzt Wiki Leaks,
Ja, weil das ist ja böse, wenn man den Leuten freien Zugang zum Netz bietet.
Vielleicht machen wir gerade nochmal kurz ein bisschen Werbung für ist nämlich sehr günstig, ja? Also ich bin auch seit langer Zeit äh glücklicher als Predator-Kunde. Das kostet so umgerechnet drei ähm je nachdem wie die schwedische Krone da steht, drei bis vier Euro oder was im oder vielleicht auch fünf im Monat
oder oder 15 Euro für drei Monate sind das glaube ich oder dann mal siebzehn Euro für drei Monate. Ähm und dafür kriegt man dann ein,
VPN Zugang Open, VPN ähm und das heißt, dass man,
dass der eigene Computer alle Verbindungen,
erstmal verschlüsselt nur mit dem I-Preda-Server hat und dieser hat ja ganz viele Kunden, die dorthin verbinden und,
Net äh diese Adressen um und das heißt, man kommt dann für die gegenüberliegende Stelle aus Schweden.
Nicht, oder?
Ich gehe schon davon aus, dass der Natte, der hat ja ganz viele Kleins, also muss er die nacken. Wie soll er sich denn sonst merken, dass er ganz viele Kunden hat und nur eine IP, durch die er rausgeht?
Da geht er nur mit einer IP raus.
Na, wenn er jedem eine eigene geben würde, wäre er auch nicht günstig.
Na wenn du.
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass sie weniger IP-Adressen als Kunden haben, also muss er nein.
Wenn man PV 4 macht.
Was ich hoffe.
Na, ich hoffe auch, dass die IPV sechs machen, machen sie? Wieso?
Ich hoffe das nicht, weil das weil ich in dem Bereich dann lieber nicht vor sechs sprechen möchte. Erstmal. Aber ist ein persönliches Gefühl.
Welchen Bereich.
Also das Problem oder kriegst du das Problem bei Open VPN ist, dass du dass die lange Zeit kein vor sechs vernünftig konnten? Und deine große Sorge war, dass V sechs nämlich dein IPV4 VPN,
untergräbt,
Deswegen äh bin ich in bin ich auf Maschinen, wo ich ein anonymes VPN haben möchte, äh fahre ich eher kein vor sechs. Und ich bin gerade nicht sicher, ob iPader vor sechs spricht.
Aber dass äh das jetzt nur am Rande, also auf jeden Fall, man kommt dann mit einer gemeinsamen Anonymisierten IP aus Schweden und ich hoffe, wie gesagt, nochmal ganz besonders, dass der weil wenn er es nicht tun würde, könnte jemand, der den Eye Predator Server überwacht sehen, wer welche IP ist.
Weil dann müsste ich nur gucken und sehe, aha, da kommt der Linus verschlüsselt rein. Der sendet jetzt gerade was,
und auf der anderen kommt das jetzt gerade unverschlüsselt raus. Deswegen willst du, dass möglichst viele dahin kommen, die ganze Zeit irgendwas hinschicken und auf einer IP am anderen Ende das alles rauskommt, in alle Richtungen, sodass
da ein großer Datenstrom rauskommt, den ich als Überwacher, der auf der Leitung zum steht, nicht feststellen kann, von wem jetzt am Ende was kam.
Hm. Na ja, gut.
Der größere Teil des Traffics bei Predator wird sowieso intern geroutet, weil durch die Nähe zu, also durch die personelle Nähe zu ist Predator auch recht beliebt bei,
ähm,
nutzen. Und äh wenn man mal in so einen äh Schwarm reingeht, wird man feststellen, wenn man da mal dann äh Anwalt spielt und sich die IP-Adressen geben lässt, stellt man fest, dass relativ viele davon,
zum Netz gehören. Und wenn ich jetzt quasi überall Predator äh mache, dann findet das Routing direkt innerhalb von iPreda statt.
Was unter Umständen führt das dazu, dass man noch noch schneller runterladen kann als das mit dem tollen Betonprotokoll ohnehin schon der Fall ist. Ähm,
langer Rede, kurzer Sinn, wie gesagt, beliebt bei Fallschirm und bei allen Leuten, die irgendwie äh entweder eine Anonymisierungsbedürfnis im Netz haben oder eben ein Zensurumgehungsbedürfnis im Netz haben und als,
Dienstleister für oder als Anbieter dieser Dienstleistung hat natürlich jetzt gerade die hohe Adelung erfahren,
relativ offensichtlich auf Direktive der irgendeiner US-Regierung,
ihnen die hat der die Möglichkeiten dort Geld hinzuschicken eingefroren werden und,
Das wiederum heißt das Appredator oder das ist wiederum ermöglicht die Interpretation, dass Appredator tatsächlich wirkt.
Was ja auch immer noch so oder ob die auch vertrauenswürdig sind, weil ja immer so die Frage, macht jetzt erstmal so den Eindruck? Ähm,
Wie gesagt, Anfang Juli, Visa und Mastercard, die hatten dann irgendwie ihre,
Online-Zahlungsdienstanbieter dann da angewiesen, haben gesagt, äh sie dürfen das äh dürfen das nicht mehr annehmen. Ähm ist da derjenige, der das dann äh geliebt hat und jetzt zieht auch PayPal nach.
Weil eine der oder die andere große Zahlungsmöglichkeit bei iPader war eben PayPal.
So und dadurch, dass sie jetzt, also wenn du weder durch ähm.
Weder durch Paypal, noch durch äh durch durch deine Kreditkarte das bezahlen kannst, dann äh bist du jetzt äh begrenzt auf,
ähm.
Ein paar andere äh Dienstleister und Bitcoin.
Wo gibt's denn die hier noch? K und ich, wo sehe ich das denn mal gerade, wie ich bezahlen kann?
Mal jetzt wirklich eine äh interessante Option jetzt sowas nicht mit Bitcoin zu kaufen.
Ja, mit Bitcoin ist super, also sollte man ohnehin, weil äh natürlich man das Problem eingeht, wenn äh wenn ich mit PayPal bezahle, dann weiß iPreda immerhin
wissen sie dann überhaupt, wer ich bin, ja? Nicht nur wissen sie, was meine IP-Adresse ist und könnten da in,
im Zweifelsfall Probleme haben, sondern äh sie wissen auch von wo ich aus bezahle.
Also wäre ich tatsächlich bin, weil ich ja mit einem Account bezahle, der irgendwo anders wirklich auf meinen Namen registriert.
Mhm.
Also ja, ey, I Predator geht's an den Kragen und das ist natürlich schlecht. Ja, weil das heißt, also wir sehen da äh,
Ja, schon, wir schweifen viel zu sehr aus. Wir sehen da, dass das also jetzt gegen,
Solche Anonyme Anonymisierungsanbieter eben da auch vorgegangen wird. Und die sind natürlich ein Dorn im Auge von äh von solchen
und wenn da plötzlich äh,
jemand dafür sorgt, dass das Nutzer sich äh nicht auf direktem Wege überwachbar machen, ne.
Je nachdem wie die Route nach Schweden läuft, kann ich mir sogar vorstellen, dass die Briten und die äh Amerikaner sich da sogar sehr besonders drüber ärgern, wenn halb Europa auf einmal mit Alpredator spricht.
Ja und das ganze Problem ist letzten Endes aber mal wieder die amerikanische Regierung, weil die ist diejenige, die den Druck ausübt auf Mastercard und äh Visa.
Ist nirgendwo dokumentiert, aber von alleine werden Mastercard, Visa und Paper sicher nicht ausgedacht haben,
zumal man deren äh deren Verhalten jetzt schon aus der äh Banking-Blockade gegen Wiki Leaks kennt, die ja sogar ähm dann irgendwann nach weiß ich nicht wie viel Jahren,
vor Gericht dann aufgehoben wurde. Also inzwischen kann man ja wieder mit ja sicher.
Dot org oder was? Das war ein nicht besonders ähm,
nicht mit nicht mit besonders viel Aufmerksamkeit äh äh bedachte Neuigkeit, aber äh Wiki Leaks hat ähm.
Gerichtlich Recht bekommen, dass das nicht akzeptabel war, was die da gemacht haben,
so, was was nimmt's im Moment entgegen? Würde mich jetzt Donald Visa Mastercard.
Geht. Krass. Das hat sich schon vor einiger Zeit geändert. Ich meine, es wäre auch bezahlt, äh dass bezahlt. Dass wir es auch berichtet hätten,
Und sie tun's jetzt trotzdem einfach nochmal wieder mit mit äh mit. Also es ist eine es ist so skandalös, also man es fällt einem dann nur noch wenig zu ein.
Es ist wirklich, es ist wirklich übel, ja? Also das ist ein, dieser Alpredator ist wirklich ein Dienst, der äh,
ja, der, wie gesagt, ich vor vielen Dingen schützt, eben auch vor der Verfolgung bei,
im Falle des aber natürlich auch sehr sehr viele andere sinnvolle Anwendungen hat, ne.
Ja und das äh geht natürlich nicht, weil damit würde man sich ja den Autoritäten entziehen und,
mögen die Autoritäten nun mal gar nicht.
Also.
Es ist auch so dieses dieses äh dieses also ohne Angabe von Gründen. Es hat diese dieses Schmierige, ne, dieses wir machen's über die Privatwirtschaft. Und das ist sowieso, ey, immer, immer wenn die Privatwirtschaft irgendwo was durchsetzt, ja, also wenn wenn man sagt, wir wir,
Wir machen das gar nicht über über Gesetze oder so. Wir wollen einfach, wir drohen Google einfach an, dass sie,
Ähm dass sie äh Pornographie jetzt sperren müssen, sonst regnet's Ärger. Ja? Wir drohen ähm wie so ein Mastercard an, dass sie äh doch bitte einfach die drei Euro, die die Leute im Monat an diesen Dienstzahlen nicht mehr durchstellen sollen, ja?
Genau, es ist eigentlich totale äh politische Willkür.
Das ist genau das, was man,
Also wie gesagt, ich bin ja ein ein ein großer äh Fan der Demokratie. Mir wurde ja viel eingeimpft über die Demokratie. Aber genau diese Willkür war immer das, was mir als der Gewinn
des Rechtsstaats irgendwie verkauft wurde, ja? Dass man sagen konnte, es gibt eben keine Willkür mehr, es gibt ein es gibt ein
Richter vor der entscheiden muss ob irgendwas in Ordnung ist oder nicht.
Und der ist unabhängig.
Und der ist unabhängig. Ja und in USA äh dann diese Betonung eine Jury, du hast das Recht auf eine Jury aus deinen,
Ja, wenn man das aber so durchklärt, dann dann sind wir wieder bei der bei der Wildüberherrschaft, die wir halt und in den Monarchien hatten. Ah, wie.
Naja, hast ja recht. Ich meine, ist äh nur angemessen, sich hier aufzuregen und es wird eigentlich viel zu wenig aufgeregt. Ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht freue ich mich jetzt schon auf Wahl äh Stände.
Also, schade, wenn die dann alle auf die Fresse kriegen.
Nee, aber das äh kann ich ja jedem nur äh empfehlen. Also wer so so eine gewisse äh Empörungsdichte erreicht hat, äh mittlerweile, ja, also äh Sascha Lobe ist ja schon beim Ekel angekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die
Kolumne gelesen hast, äh ersteigert sich. Ähm aber,
Ich finde ja äh wirklich mal interessant, was jetzt,
grade so äh die Parteien der äh Regierung und damit schließe ich,
explizit auch die SPD mit ein, ja, weil die ist äh ausreichend an der Regierung,
in gewisser Hinsicht natürlich auch die Grünen. Es geht ja auch einiges äh zurück.
Ähm und da sind wir eigentlich auch schon beim nächsten Thema, oder?
Ähm ja ja genau, wir können eigentlich hier so einen fliegenden Themenübergang machen, ja.
Machen wir einen äh fliegenden Themen äh Übergang. Also ähm verschiedener äh ähm Basisinformationen, um sich in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten an Wahlständen auszukotzen. Diese generelle Frage natürlich nach.
Besserungsvorschläge, einfach mal konstruktive Kritik.
Ne, ich würde mich vor, ich würde mir das vor allem auch gerne mal so herleiten lassen von solchen äh Menschen, die da irgendwie diese Politik vertreten.
Gemein? Ist doch gemein.
Das ist gemahlen.
Du weißt doch, dass sie das einfach nur äh aus aus ganz anderen.
Ganz ehrlich, ganz äh ja, ich meine, Zynismus, alles super, ja, aber,
es gibt eine erste Riege ja die in was weiß ich welche die irgendwie,
aber jetzt hast du da eine Basis, die äh ermuntert wird von,
Platzhaltern äh doch jetzt mal hier das Finchen zu,
und äh das Wimpelchen schön in den Wind zu halten, ne?
Die machen das, ja.
Wimpel im Wind und ähm dann stellen die sich da jetzt hin und dann würde mich mal wirklich die Sprachregelung interessieren, die die jetzt an den Tag legen, um diese Scheiße zu rechtfertigen,
Das wird schwierig. Ich meine, die Situation ist mittlerweile so verkackt, das könnte jetzt sogar,
Ist ja noch nicht mal vollkommen auszuschließen, dass die Piratenpartei nicht untergeht. So weit sind wir schon.
So und was kommt neu raus irgendwie? Äh weiteres wie wie nennt man dieses Verhalten? Ich finde auch gar kein Wort mehr zu. Also die die deutsche Bundesregierung windet sich.
Und sagt vor allem erstmal nichts. Und wenn sie dann mal was sagen, stellt es sich meistens auch innerhalb kürzester Zeit als äh falsch heraus.
Ja
Was wahrscheinlich der primäre Grund ist, dass sie einfach nichts sagen, weil sie gerade das Gefühl haben, dass sie entweder nur Sachen sagen, für die sie sofort auf die Schlachtbank kommen oder sofort der Lüge überführt.
Ja gut, du musst auch wissen, der war ja jetzt sieben Wochen im Urlaub.
Sieben also gefühlt.
Der war im Urlaub, hat ne, also was was ist geschehen?
Es wurde gesagt es kam dann ja die Meldung, dass gesagt wurde na ja Freunde,
hier in diesem Afghanistan-Bericht steht ja schon irgendwie 2007 was von Prisum drin. Also könnt ihr doch nicht ernsthaft erzählen, dass ihr nicht wisst, was ist,
Und dann haben sie sich hingestellt, haben gesagt, ja Moment, das äh ist ja ein anderes Prisum.
Das ist das Militär Prison. Äh es gibt aber äh noch ein äh,
Das andere Prisum, was eben von den benannten von AdWordsNorden benannten neuen Internetfirmen, neuen Internetfirmen, Daten sammelt. Das ist eben dieses äh da ist andere Prison.
Nein, nein, Herr Richter, wir haben gar keine Software auf unserem Computer. Das sind alles Applikationen.
Ja, sofern. So, jetzt sagt er und jetzt kommt er, jetzt ist genau der spannende. Du sagst, du sagst das schon richtig. Es sind ja,
sogar im Prinzip zwei verschiedene Prisums,
Nur det ist scheißegal, ob das jetzt Prisum oder temporär oder X Kiescore ist, es ist ein Überwachungssystem und ähm.
Jetzt kommt ja noch der der Witz, also dieses,
Dieses ursprünglich von geliebte Prison, was also jetzt irgendwie Datenextraktion von oder bei den Providern ist,
ja? Das ist ja bei weitem nicht so übel, wie dieses Tempora, was die Briten machen, wo sie sagen, wir machen einfach mal,
full take. Wir wir dampfen einfach mal den kompletten Traffic äh hier auf unsere.
Wobei wir eh glaube ich davon ausgehen können, dass es auf der anderen Seite des Kabels genauso getan wird.
Richtig, genau, aber so und jetzt stellt sich,
raus. Ähm dass es dann ja noch, das kam jetzt grade, dass es dann dieses Ex-Kiescorp gibt. Ja, wo also äh,
So und die sind ja, das sind alles Systeme, die sind da ja nicht untereinander ähm der sitzt ja jetzt nicht der NSA-Mann und sagt, wo gucke ich denn jetzt mal.
Starte
Jetzt klicke ich in meinem Blog auf exkiescore und gucke da und jetzt kriege ich in meinem und gucke da. Am Ende haben die ja sowieso alles in einer mehr oder weniger zusammengeführten Nutzeroberfläche, wo einfach reinspült, äh was es gibt,
trennen die ja nicht mehr, wäre ja totaler Irrsinn, die 500 Mark nicht auch noch auszugeben, um zu sagen, äh am Ende möchten wir das bitte alles in einer
Unified Interface haben, ja? Insofern,
Ja, wendet sich die Bundesregierung und sagt, ja, hier gibt's das eine Prisum und das andere Prisum.
Erbärmlichkeit nicht mehr zu unterbieten,
Und dann äh heißt es auf einmal, ja und übrigens, was sind hier mit Ex-Keescore, ja? Worüber der Spiegel schreibt, da werden monatlich bis zu fünfhundert Millionen,
Datensätze aus Deutschland erfasst von der NSA und der Spiegel stellt recherchiert eben und sagt, naja, genau dieses System
steht auch deutschen Geheimdiensten zur Verfügung. Und dann meldet sich der äh sagt erst keiner was dazu. Und dann sagt der Hans-Georg Maaßen, der ist jetzt neu beim BND, nachdem sein Vorgänger über die NSU-Affäre dann,
den Mut nehmen muss, den Schlapphut nehmen musste. Ähm ja, dann sagt der Hans-Georg Maaß, ja, wir testen das.
Wie stelle ich mir jetzt so einen Geheimdienst vor, der so was mal testet? Hat der jetzt eine 30 Tage Testversion? So eine Shareware.
Mit.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das ist diese, wahrscheinlich auch wieder so eine, das wird läuft alles auf so eine Konfusion hinaus.
So und was schreibt, Andre schreibt dann auf Netzpolitik auch sehr äh sehr richtig. Das spielt jetzt echt,
es kommt ja bei den Namen eh keiner mehr hinterher. Ohne spielt jetzt auch keine Rolle mehr, wie diese Systeme heißen,
ist voll Überwachung und wir haben längst
sind wir über den Punkt hinaus, dass wir noch Daten benennen könnten, auf die die Geheimdienste nicht zugreifen.
Ja, ist eigentlich alles.
Einfach einmal alles Thema erledigt so. Und da braucht man sie jetzt nicht weiter äh noch.
Namen zu streiten.
Über Namen zu streiten. Zumal, wenn das noch es zwei Prisums gibt, ja. Also ich meine, spätestens an dem Punkt ähm brauchst du nicht mehr weiter zu argumentieren, ja. Und.
Nein, ein Doppelprisma ist das sozusagen.
So und jetzt äh jetzt tut sich aber politisch so langsam ein bisschen was, ja? Denn also halten wir nochmal fest, alles,
wird am Ende alles in allem ist das am Ende das eine große Überwachungssystem mit dem einfach alles gemacht wird. Da mögen dann Untersysteme nochmal getrennt sein und
vorgefiltert werden, bevor die NSA, die wieder mit den, mit den Idioten vom BND teilt, die ja eine international auf der geheim auf dem Geheimdienstparkett einfach kein besonders guten Ruf haben und auch national nicht so hin und her.
BND testet das gerade. So, was.
Dass sie das einsetzen, sie testen.
Testen, Testversion.
Ja, das ist.
Da kommt jedes Mal so ein Pop-Up. Äh hier äh Globals Aylins, Ex-Keescore, äh,
Don't use the crack version.
Ich meine, ich finde, ich finde diesen Ausblick, dass auch die Geheimdienste Testversionen fahren, ja. Äh wenn man davon ausgeht, dass die,
Geheimdienste auch alles kontrollieren. Ich meine, wir sind jetzt eh schon mitten in der vollen Aluhut-Verschwörung und so weiter, ja? Äh.
Wenn die Regierung auffälligen Geheimdiensten kontrolliert wird, vielleicht handelt es sich bei der Regierung ja auch nur um eine Testversion. Würde zumindest einiges erklären.
Ich find's halt nur, ich find's halt die Frage ist halt wer diesen Überwachungsprogramm was die jetzt genau mit Testen meinen und was ist meine Rolle, ja? Bin ich da jetzt grade der Betatester oder der Betatest?
Als Linus Neumann mit meinen Datenverkehr. Ja. Ähm ich habe mich am Wochenende mit einem ähm.
Mit äh einem äh einem Menschen unterhalten, der auch äh ins Fadenskreuz der USA geraten ist aufgrund bestimmter Vorkommnisse vor ein paar Jahren. Ähm,
Und der hat handelt sich dabei um einen sehr klugen Menschen und der hat dann gesagt, wenn das, also wenn wenn dieser,
Das, was wir jetzt gerade erleben, so diese Global Global Swaylands, ja,
noch dazu irgendwie fliegende Roboter, die Menschen töten. Wenn du das vor zehn Jahren hätte keine Sau den Film gucken wollen,
Also wir sind, inzwischen haben wir wirklich mit unserer Gesellschaft die Science Fiction, die da irgendwie mit mit oder mit äh mit oder mit irgendwelchen komischen ähm Büchern und Filmen äh gestaltet wurde. Die haben wir,
ja. Haben wir überholt.
Das ist schon wirklich krass.
Möchte er noch äh ein kurz ein Wort zu verlieren, weil in den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung dann auch irgendwie ähm,
dann darauf hingewiesen wurde, dass jetzt, ne, dass wir jetzt hier alle verschlüsseln müssen und so, ne? Und dann äh dann wird das alles wieder gut, wenn wir jetzt PGP nutzen. Also ich meine,
PGP nutzen wir seit 20 Jahren. Ihr Nutzer seit 20 Jahren nicht.
Ja und ähm das macht die Sache nicht besser, weil du immer noch diese bekannten Mieterdaten hast, die eben dann darin bestehen, dass äh man eben sieht, wer mit wem kommuniziert, was sowieso das viel schlimmere ist.
Eben, also es ist,
das nützt halt sich wenig und gerade ich will jetzt nicht das Fass aufmachen, aber ich denke dieser dieser Glaube ähm man müsste ja nur eine bestimmte richtige Maßnahme äh machen. Das würde dann irgendwas äh,
helfen, das ist einfach Quatsch, ja? Also das,
man kann einfach durch das Beobachten von Rahmeninformationen sehr viel mehr rausbekommen und es ist sogar so, dass die Geheimdienste tatsächlich an diesen Metadaten zunächst einmal viel mehr Interesse haben
ähm als an irgendwelchen Inhalten, weil das ist viel zu schwierig und viel zu vieldeutig und so weiter, während die Mieterdaten eine relativ klare Sprache sprechen, ne
Und man.
Kennst du auch vom Datenniveau her einfacher äh also statistische Operationen wie jetzt Korrelationen und sowas kannst du halt auf
auf diese äh Meterdaten sehr, sehr viel besser anwenden, ja, als jetzt auf so ein auf Wortfilter oder asiatische Analysen, die haben benötigen sehr, sehr viel,
nicht im gewinnst, nicht,
Information nicht in einem vernünftigen Verhältnis zum Informationsgewinn stehenden Ausmaß.
Mit anderen Worten, das lohnt nicht. Du warst mit den Metadaten, die hast du relativ einfach, kannst du super Analysen mitmachen und der Informationsgewinn, den du dafür hast, äh diese Inhaltsanalysen zu machen, der ist relativ gering,
gemessen an dem Rechenaufwand, der dafür betrieben werden muss.
Genau. Ich.
Deswegen also PGP schön und gut, macht das alle. Ich ähm,
und ne, wer hätte da schon vor vielen Jahren machen müssen, ja? Und ähm hilft eben auch gegen bestimmte,
an gegen bestimmte Angriffsszenarien, aber da 99 Prozent von euch ohnehin nicht,
im genaueren ähm im genaueren Fokus der Fahnen, der der Geheimdienste geradestehen, ändert sich an eure,
Persönlichen Überwachungssituation nichts. Sie wird unter Umständen nur schlechter, weil man sieht, dass eure E-Mails auf einmal mit Beginn äh PGP-Message anfangen. Und äh deswegen ähm nochmal ändert.
Na, der hat ja offensichtlich etwas zu verbergen.
Genau, kommt er in die gelbe Stadt, in die grüne Gruppe. Und wenn er Pech hat, äh lädt euer Computer dann äh mit dem nächsten mit dem nächsten Softwareupdate äh eine Infektion runter. Wir hatten das ja schon. Das wird ja,
viele Folgen her, aber da hatten wir das ja schon besprochen, wie diese on the fly, äh die von Staatstrojanern geht. Was meint ihr, was was ähm Geheimdienste machen?
Hm. Ja und schon äh leben wir wieder ein weiteres Beispiel von Überwachung,
führt zu Verhaltensänderungen, ja? Besser man nicht verschlüsseln, weil das kriegen sie ja gleich mit und dann falle ich ja auf so, ne? Das ist äh definitiv so ein Aspekt,
Und gleich mal irgendwie den familienfreundlichen Pornofilter
anklicken, weil sonst könnte man ja noch glauben, ich will jetzt hier irgendwie.
Ja
Nachher schicken sie mir dann noch die rote Fritzbox statt der schwarzen, weißt du? Und die steht dann bei mir im Flur. Und jeder weiß, so irgendwie so so werden diese huch, so werden diese Sachen gemacht. Ich bin hier, warte, ich habe deinen Stuhl, glaube ich, grade irgendwie herausgefordert.
Ähm wir schweifen ab.
Ja, wir schweifen ab. Wo waren wir denn eigentlich? Beim BND und dein äh Test äh äh Varianten und so weiter.
Wird getestet. Die äh IFF hat dann ihr kommt mit irgendeiner Sammelklage an. Ich will jetzt mal so kurz was jetzt was jetzt gemacht wird. Also IFF,
streng eine Sammelklage an. Wer weiß, was daraus wird. Irgendwie gegen das, gegen die NSA-Machenschaften. Dann kommt die äh EU-Kommissare in Reding daher und stellt dieses Safe Harber-Abkommen in Frage. Das Gleiche macht ähm die,
Datenschutz äh Konferenz. Das Save-Haber-Abkommen ähm sagt, dass ähm.
Daten, die in die USA gehen, dort per se als den den Datenschutzgrund äh den Datenschutzrichtlinien entsprechend aufbewahrt gelten.
Ist das richtig gesagt.
Ja, das ist sozusagen äh man einfach so per, per Aklamation, einfach feststellt, äh ist egal, ob's hier oder da ist, passt schon. So. Woran natürlich vor allem die USA äh die USA ähm,
großes Interesse haben sozusagen, das heißt US-Firmen würden dann quasi nach dieser U EU-Derektive sich
verhalten und so pauschal den Datenschutz entsprechend und passt schon und dann gibt's halt keine Einschränkungen mehr und dann darf Firma X auch in der amerikanischen Cloud seine Dokumente abschmeißen, weil ist ja total sicher.
Genau, insbesondere personenbezogene Daten, weil das eben nach Datenschutz äh Richtlinien eben nicht so einfach möglich wäre. Es geht jetzt um ein äh Vereinbarung zwischen EU,
Europäischer Union und äh Vereinigten Staaten, wo dann sagt, wo man sagt, okay, mit dieser die Datenschutzrichtlinie verbietet zwar grundsätzlich persönliche äh personenbezogene Daten,
in andere aus einem EU-Mitgliedsstaat in einen anderen Staat zu übertragen,
in dem nicht das Gleiche EU das gleiche Datenschutzniveau. Ui ui ui schöne Vespa hier,
PK fuffzig. Ähm.
Die EU-Datenschutzrichtlinie verbietet es, Daten in einem anderen Land zu speichern, in dem nicht das Gleiche oder ein höheres Datenschutzniveau besteht. Und sagt,
Bei den USA geht das klar. Das ist per Gesetz das gleiche Datenschutzniveau. Das sagt das Safehaberabkommen.
Ist es eigentlich scheißegal wir wollen hier keine Beschränkungen haben bitte vorspulen.
Genau. Und jetzt sagt,
sagt also redigen und die die äh Datenschutzkonferenz ähm bei ausreichendem Zweifel kann dieses Safehaber-Abkommen ausgesetzt werden. Und,
Ausreichender Zweifel ist ja wohl jetzt gegeben, also ausreichender Zweifel, dass mit den Daten dort den der EU-Richt-Datenschutzrichtlinie entsprechend umgegangen wird. Und,
Ähm natürlich hat das ganze Ding dann so eine Ausnahmeklause der nationalen Sicherheit,
Oder also drinsteht, die USA dürfen da nicht drauf zugreifen, außer in Felder äh Nationalsecher. Und das äh ist ja genau ein National Security Agency, ja.
Das ist die nationale Sicherheit.
Dass wir denen im Namen, ja.
Und ähm jetzt sagt also die Datenschutzkonferenz, sagt die ähm Bundesregierung soll also jetzt ja ähm,
Abkommen aussetzen oder erklären, warum sie meinen, das nicht tun zu müssen. Und das Gleiche, die gleiche äh das Gleiche verlangen, äh richten sie natürlich an die EU-Kommission. Ähm,
Weiterhin sitzen jetzt in der EU viele auf die äh auf die auf die Datenschutznovelle,
Die wir hier ja schon mehrfach besprochen haben, Kirsten Fiedler hatte dazu äh gesprochen, Benjamin Bergemann ähm.
Plug, der ganze Kram. Ich hab's Gefühl, dir die Hälfte der Sendung hat sich darum gedreht, auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. Zu Recht, ja.
Da setzen sie jetzt drauf, dass dass damit die US äh Spionage unterbunden wird. Halte ich für ein Ziel, aber für.
Ja, glaube ich, also ich weiß nicht genau, ob also mein Verständnis. Ich bin jetzt vorsichtig. Das sind Leute, die haben da mehr Ahnung von als ich. Deswegen bin ich da vorsichtig, das zu kritisieren. Aber mein Verständnis ist, dass Geheimdienste nicht an Gesetze gebunden sind.
Nicht so genau nehmen.
Genau. Und deswegen halte ich das für unwahrscheinlich.
Also sie sind an Gesetze gebunden, aber an.
Dienst gesehen.
Geheime Gesetze. Ja, ich meine, das ist ein System, da in USA, wo geheime äh Organisationen auf geheimer Basis, auf Basis von geheimen Gesetzen,
mit geheimen äh Richtern arbeiten. Ja, das muss man sich einfach mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Also das ist diese ganze Kette
da äh irgendwie vollkommen dem der öffentlichen Kontrolle entzogen ist. Ich meine, ich kann nicht behaupten, dass wir in Deutschland auch nur ansatzweise das Gefühl haben können, hier sei irgendein Geheimdienst einer öffentlichen Kontrolle,
unterworfen, weil die ja auch offensichtlich,
Selbst wenn man dann mal mit dem passenden Kontrollgremium ankommt, auch nicht bereit sind, einfach mal alles zu erzählen, weil wenn's halt gerade nicht so, ja, das kann ich euch jetzt nicht sagen, weil das wäre schlecht für uns.
Also was die Gesetze angeht äh über die wir da sprechen, diese äh Person, mit der ich mich da äh jetzt letztens mal unterhalten habe, ist also eine Person, die schon äh seit vielen Jahren vor genau dieser Sache warnt,
Und äh also davor gewarnt hat, dass diese Welt sich in diese Richtung bewegt. Und ähm.
Ich sagte dann, ja Mensch, hör mal, was sagst du uns denn jetzt? Was sollen wir denn jetzt machen? Und dann sagte die Person, ja ich habe doch jetzt 20 Jahre lang gesagt, was wir machen müssen, um zu verhindern, dass es soweit kommt,
ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, wie man das nochmal rückgängig machen soll. Da fällt mir nichts mehr zu ein. Wir hätten es damals verhindern müssen. Wir hätten damals die Gesetze machen müssen,
Wir hätten bei jedem noch so blöden Ausnahme äh bei jeder noch so blöden Ausnahmeklausel für Fragen der nationalen Sicherheit protestieren müssen. Wir hätten das seit vielen Jahren irgendwie bekämpfen müssen. Jetzt,
ist es zu spät. Wir haben es. So, die Technik hat sich, es war klar, dass die Technik sich dahin entwickeln würde
die Situation ist jetzt auch entsprechend und das jetzt nochmal rückgängig zu machen wird sehr sehr schwierig zumal,
jedes Mal, wenn irgendjemand laut wird und sich dagegen wehrt, irgendeine Werwolfgruppe aus dem Keller kommt, äh die man seit Jahren äh äh verfolgt hätte. Die haben,
fast schon irgendwie mal über Licht einen Anschlag zu machen, den haben wir jetzt verhindert. Ja, wir kennen diese Zahlen, vielleicht fünf, vielleicht sieben. Also diesen ähm.
Den den Freiheit, statt Angst, Kampf.
Die Grundausrichtung der Gesellschaft, der hätte früher äh äh gekämpft und entschiedener gekämpft werden müssen, bevor wir äh die Angstgesellschaft hatten.
Jetzt wird es schwierig.
Jetzt haben wir die Angstgesellschaft.
Gesellschaft. Nichtsdestotrotz ähm.
Gibt's dann etwas Hoffnung,
einige Abgeordnete äh in den USA wollen das geheimdienstliche speichern nur auf Verdächtige beschränken,
Und sagen, also sie wollen quasi nicht die die anlaslose Überwachung. Das ist ja das, worum es hier geht, sondern sie wollen die veranlasste Überwachung, also zurück zur veranlassten Überwachung, quasi. Ähm,
Das müssten sie einmal durch den Kong Kongress, einmal durch den Senat und dann noch über Obamas Schreibtisch kriegen.
Paß. Mhm.
Wünsche viel Spaß, viel Erfolg und viel Glück und viel Segen, ähm die äh Chancen werden eher unrealistisch, eingeschätzt, aber wenigstens, ne, man wird sie dann irgendwann hoffentlich äh historisch würdigen, dazu wenigstens versucht haben.
Ja, also während wir uns jetzt lange Zeit über die äh Existenz oder mögliche Existenz eines Überwachungsstaats äh,
unterhalten haben, so ist jetzt eigentlich eher so was wie so eine Überwachungswelt entstanden, wo auch.
Merkwürdige Allianzen existieren,
auf einer Ebene, die auch in sich komplett geheim ist. Ja, also da arbeitet der BND,
Geheimdienst, auf geheimer Basis mit einem anderen Geheimdienst und beide äh sind jenseits,
von irgendeiner nennenswerten Kontrolle. So
und ähm man kann jetzt auch locker mal noch Kanada, Neuseeland, äh Britannien
mit reinschmeißen, Australien, also die ganzen englischsprachigen, nicht wahr? Diese five Ice, diese diese äh
Anglo viele äh Union, die es schon irgendwie immer gegeben hat und die sich schon immer am meisten vertraut hat, weil man spricht ja dieselbe Sprache und man teilt ja im Wesentlichen auch dieselbe äh Kultur, nämlich die von,
ausgehend von äh Britannien, ja und dieses britannische Modell äh ja.
Also genau das, was sozusagen auch ähm gesehen hat oder meint, gesehen zu haben,
Das erhebt sich jetzt quasi über den Rest der Welt und äh führt da so eine Überwachung durch. Ich freue mich natürlich auch, was so die anderen unbeteiligten Geheimdienste ähm,
noch alles so darüber denken mögen, ja? Ich glaube im Wesentlichen sind die alle jetzt so ein bisschen wie man sagen.
Ich glaube, die fühlen sich leider auch noch etwas herausgefordert jetzt, ne.
Das Spannende finde ich eigentlich,
also diese ganzen, also ob das jetzt Neuseeland, Kanada, UK, USA sind, diese ganzen Geheimdienste ähm,
die da miteinander zu einem gewissen Grad an offensichtlich zusammenarbeiten oder auch wie der BND mit den USA ähm oder mit der NSA und anderen Geheimdiensten. Ähm,
Geheimdienste oder auch auf EU-Ebene, die Geheimdienste arbeiten ja auch alle zusammen. Diese, also mit welcher.
Wie die wiederum, die müssen ja immer noch mal eine Grenze dieser Zusammenarbeit haben, weil die ja,
selber auch nochmal das Interesse natürlich haben, mehr von der Zusammenarbeit zu profitieren, als
durch diese Zusammenarbeit zu verlieren, ja? Also
Selbstverständlich, wir haben das in der letzten Sendung ja schon angesprochen, geht's ja auch um äh Spionage, wirtschaftliche Vorteile in diesen in diesen Angelegenheiten. Und den Teil muss ja jeder Geheimdienst dann wiederum äh ausklammern.
Ist auch ein schöner Talking Point für die Diskussion am an Wahlständen in den nächsten Monaten,
ist zwei Monaten, ja, also grad so bei der FDP, fände ich das mal ja ganz interessant, die auch mal so für die Freiheit äh eintritt, TM, ja.
Ja, sind doch alle frei.
Ja, die auch sagen wir mal immer den Mittelstand zu zugewandt ist, also äh was sie sozusagen jetzt davon halten, dass quasi de facto der deutsche Mittelstand, der sich so rein technisch schon äh
gar nicht leisten kann, ja?
Äh sich da in irgendeiner Form durch irgendeine Verschlüsselung zu wehren, geschweige denn, dass du überhaupt eine eine realistische Chance hast, das heutzutage äh zu machen, weil so wie du früher halt mal ein Fax geschickt hast.
Wahrscheinlich auch wissen, wo diese Faxe so landen. Ähm hast du halt jetzt äh das entsprechende Äquivalent einer E-Mail, was eben auch mehr oder weniger direkt abgegriffen wird.
Und da liegt er dann halt so der äh der Schatz, das wäre mit wem und wer äh
eigentlich mit wem und schicken Sie doch mal den Vertragsentwurf Frau Peyer und äh wo ist
sind hier äh können sie mir nochmal die Bestätigung schicken und so, weißt du? So läuft auch der Hase und das äh sind natürlich alles so, man kann im einen diesen,
Workflow, Business-Workflow kritisieren. Auf der anderen Seite muss man aber auch klar sehen,
Diese Gesellschaft hat eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung, glaube ich. Und es ist
Meiner Meinung nach, ich überlege ja auch mal wieder dieses so, wie wie stehe ich dazu, wie äh verhalte ich mich da drin?
Warum verschlüssel ich nicht? Warum bin ich nicht ausreichend paranoid? Warum trage ich kein Aluhut, ja? Sind so Fragen, die ich mir auch mal wieder äh stelle. Und,
Ich glaube, dass auch viele deshalb ähm nicht bereit waren, auf diesen Zug aufzuspringen, weil sie's einfach,
nicht wirklich für möglich gehalten haben.
Ja. Und dass man so mit seinem Grund.
Psychologisches Ding. Wenn du darauf einsteigst und so in diese,
paranoide Weltsicht,
Ja, das meine ich jetzt gar nicht mal negativ, aber sozusagen so dieses generelle wahrscheinliches, alles bedrohlich Prämisse. Ja, wenn du daran einsteigst, dass du darunter einfach selber leidest, weil du in so etwas nicht leben willst,
Das heißt, du gehst einfach mal davon aus, dass das nicht so ist, weil du das ja nicht willst,
du irgendwie auch das Gefühl hast, dass wenn du jetzt da deine schlechte äh Laune äh mit rein trägst, dass du es auch für alle anderen schlecht machst? Und so ist das ja auch, ne? So.
Auch so diese Diskussion an diesem Wochenende und dann kriegt man dann irgendwie so gesagt so, ja, alles Scheiße. Alles scheiße, alles kaputt, alles zu Ende, vorbei,
Sorry, 20 Jahre zu spät. Und dann sitzt du da so. Denkst dir so, aber aber die Vögel zwitschern doch und die Sonne scheint und.
Sonne scheint.
Ja, bitte. Nee. Es ist einfach hart. Das will keiner.
Ich glaube, da flüchtet dann auch das Hirn. So wie du, wenn du wie du verrückt wirst, wenn du in der Zelle sitzt. Und dann hörst du irgendwann die Vögelchen wieder. Aber sind halt keine da.
Ich habe da es äh flog ein Cartoon an mir vorbei, ich werde den nochmal raussuchen
da äh man sieht also ein ein Typ, der so in der Gummizelle sitzt mit seiner Zwangsjacke, die ganze Gummizelle ist voll geschrieben mit, die überwachen uns, die beobachten uns, sie hören uns ab und der Flieger steht so da und sagt, äh sie können gehen, sieht so aus, als hätten sie recht.
Macht so die Tür auf.
Das ist die Situation, in der wir uns befinden. Ja. Und ich glaube auch, also du hast Recht, dass das irgendwie in diesem Ausmaß vielleicht fürn.
Für einen Menschen, der in dieser Gesellschaft irgendwie lebt, eben nicht mehr zu erfassen ist, nicht mehr vorstellbar ist.
Ja, es schaltet einfach was.
Wir haben ja auch gelernt in den, also zumindest in den letzten ähm ja jetzt doch schon 60, 70 Jahren äh dass man so einer Regierung vertrauen kann.
65 Jahre, 68 Jahre lang, ja? Ungefähr wurde so in wurde so gesagt, diese Regierung ist gut so. Man kann der vertrauen,
Es gibt einen es gibt einen Feind. Wir haben immer einen schönen Feind gehabt, ja? Kommunisten, Islamisten, irgendjemand gab's immer, das waren auch Milliarden von Menschen, die in Frieden leben, ja. Genauso eine Gesellschaft, eine genauso funktionierende Gesellschaft wie unsere auch, mit ein paar anderen äh Regeln,
Paar anderen wirtschaftlichen Interessen, das waren dann die Bösen, aber ähm.
Und einen Freund hatten wir auch einen großen. Mhm.
Großen Freund hatten wir und das war schon alles immer in Ordnung so und das auch sehr komfortabel äh sich darin so äh ne, also so diese diese Einsicht, das war jetzt eventuell doch alles nur.
Also oder,
Vielleicht also vielleicht nicht die einzig, dass es immer alles schlecht war. Aber die Einsicht zu sehen, dass es sich jetzt zu etwas ganz, ganz grausamen und grässlichen entwickelt hat,
die ist dieser Schritt ist mit sehr, sehr vielen äh Konsequenzen für das eigene Erleben und Denken verbunden und ähm,
wird aus einer geistigen Trägheit dann auch eher gemieden. Ja, also das möchte man lieber nicht.
Sich darüber Gedanken machen. Also wir haben, glaube ich, jetzt lange genug darüber geredet. Natürlich, ne? Wir wissen, man kann immer dagegen demonstrieren, wir sind ja in einer Demokratie, Freunde.
Und am 277. können wir alle unter dem Hashtag stop watching as gegen Prison,
Temper protestieren und wahrscheinlich auch gegen Ex-Keescore und äh was es noch alles gibt.
Das andere Prison auch.
Das andere Prison Prison und Prison.
Genau. Wir sind gegen beides.
Wir haben beides, Prison und Prison.
Welche Form von Überwachung macht ihr denn hier?
Ja, das ist deutschlandweit oder was? Oder europaweit oder.
Also ich habe das äh.
Deutschlandweit, heißt es hier.
Deutschlandweit auf jeden Fall. Äh genau, da sind jetzt erstmal nur ähm,
So und da also bei Netzpolitik org, Markus findet da auch nochmal die richtigen Worte. Es wird eben gegen die größte Überwachungsmaschinerie der Menschheit
demonstriert. Das ist das Ausmaß, mit dem wir hier zu tun haben.
Es gab in den Kommentaren dann einige äh zu den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung, einige Hinweise, dass ich das ja wohl etwas übertrieben übertreiben würde und ich möchte sogar sagen, dass ich letzte Woche noch untertrieben habe, was das Ausmaß angeht, aber egal.
Stop-Watchingers sind die Proteste, wir haben den Link dazu es in in Unmengen an Unmengen an Schnitten findet das statt,
Bis dahin. Wird bestimmt was ändern. Ähm.
Dann gibt's noch eine es gibt so eine eine mittel gute Nachricht.
Ja. Bitte gute Nachrichten.
Vodafone Red ist kein grenzenloses Surfen. Hat das, klar hat das Landgericht,
die Klage der des Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverbandes hatten wir glaube ich besprochen
war dann in Folge auf die äh Aktion der digitalen Gesellschaft, wo dann eben kritisiert wurde, dass die äh Vodafone-Tarife nicht
Netz neutral sind, weil sie ähm ihr Top hier und Voice of IP und alle möglichen Formen von Traffic sperren.
Und ähm.
Da hatte dann eben Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband äh auch geklagt. Ich meine, wir hätten darüber äh gesprochen und,
Landgericht Düsseldorf, deshalb, weil Vodafone äh in Düsseldorf sitzt ähm die Zentrale äh und da hat äh Vodafone in diesem,
Fall jetzt äh am 197. dem Urteil verloren und dürfen jetzt den Vodafone Red-Tarif nicht mehr so äh.
Bewerben, wir sehen die Netzgemeinde, die kann auch richtig was reißen.
Und die Demokratie siegt am Ende. Am Ende wird alles gut.
Verbraucherschutz haben wir noch.
Ja, heute haben wir schon eine Werbekampagne äh gestoppt, was was kommt morgen?
Noch ein noch noch was aus dem Bereich der Netzneutralität. Es gab ja den äh es war, glaube ich, im Chaos-Radio als äh Clemens äh oder hatte er das auch im Logbuch schon mal erzählt. Ähm,
Der Vorschlag doch mal äh so ein managed Service bei der Telekom einfach mal anzufragen.
Und zu sagen, ey Freunde, wir wollen den gleichen Deal wie Spotify hier für die Metaebene Podcasts oder für die Podcasts von Netzpolitik Org haben. Ähm,
Netzpolitik Org hat das dann mal gemacht und hat äh hat die Telekom angefangen, hat gesagt, hey, wir wollen hier so ein wir wir haben gehört, ihr macht jetzt Managed Service, das wollen wir ganz gerne auch haben, ja? Äh sag doch mal einen Preis,
Und äh Clemens hatte ja schon richtig gesagt, das Schöne ist, dass sie, dass man dann entweder den Preis kennt,
oder dass sie einen diskriminieren. Und das können sie ja nicht, weil sie ja sagen, sie bieten die Manageservices diskriminierungsfrei an und deswegen ist das ja auch netzneutral, ja? Die Antwort äh,
die sie dann bekamen, war ähm,
Dass die öffentliche Diskussion deutlich gemacht hat, dass äh noch viele Unsicherheiten bestehen, wie die Telekom jetzt zukünftig managed,
anbieten kann und da es sowohl auf äh nationaler als auch äh auf Deutscher, als auch äh europäischer Ebene da Bestrebungen gebe,
können sie aufgrund dieser Unsicherheit grade nicht konkrete Produktvorstellungen weiterentwickeln.
Und deshalb noch keine konkreten Angebote präsentieren.
Das war natürlich eine, war natürlich eine geschickte Antwort. Interessant ist, sie haben ja trotzdem ein Deal mit Spotify, also so problematisch kann es ja alles gar nicht sein, ne. Äh wobei, na okay, Manageservice wäre dann wieder was entfesselt.
Ja, ich meine, wenn es wenn es sozusagen, also wenn diese Unsicherheit bestehen ja, also wenn es eine rechtliche Unsicherheit gibt, wie kann denn dann dieser Vertrag zustande gekommen sein.
Ja, würde man würde man sich äh wünschen, dass sie das, dass sie diesen Brief, Spotify mal schicken, ja?
Ja, also ich meine, ob dir das jetzt bedeuten würde, dass sie das jetzt kündigen und sein lassen, wenn da diese rechtlichen Unsicherheiten oder ich meine, wenn die offensichtlich macht ihnen ja die rechtliche Unsicherheit an der Stelle wenig aus, dann können sie ja dann auch trotzdem also ich meine,
Ja, wenn's dann halt nicht mehr geht, dann lässt man's dann halt danach wieder einfach sein.
Wir können ja einfach mal von der Redaktion da so ein Fuffi rüberschicken mit so einem Post-it dran haben oder nicht. Ja.
Ah genau.
Den steckt ihr euch einfach schon mal ein und wenn ihr noch Bock drauf habt, wir haben noch mehr.
Wo der herkommt, da haben wir noch mindestens zehn weitere liegen.
Ja, aber ich meine, die Lücke würde ich dann schon nochmal äh reingehen so, ne.
Ja, ich hoffe, ich gehe davon aus, dass äh das Netz für auch noch mal weiter nachfragen kann, aber diese Antwort ist, es ist natürlich schon wieder so ein Witz für sich. Also.
Aber ich gehe jetzt schon davon aus, dass äh.
Auf jeden Fall diese diskriminierungsfreie Nummer ist damit jetzt eigentlich schon.
Ist erledigt, ja.
Erledigt. Das können sie dann irgendwie nicht halten, weil offensichtlich gibt's ja eine Diskriminierung, ja. Manche äh bei manchen gibt's rechtliche Unsicherheiten,
Ja und bei bei anderen nicht so, ja, weil also entweder äh was was soll das, ne?
Also das kann man schon mal deutlich machen. Wir machen das jetzt hier mit äh.
Wir machen das hier mit deutlich. So, damit äh wären wir beim Ende der Sendung angelangt.
Oh, schon.
Ja, schon. Ähm,
Nochmal, da würde ich ja nochmal gerne zurückkommen zum zum Themenfeld der digitalen Selbstverteidigung, also der Verschlüsselung von von Kommunikationsdaten oder Daten, die man so in der Cloud ablegt, ähm,
Und zwar bin ich da morgen, am Donnerstag, den was ist das denn dann? Der.
Der fünfundzwanzigste.
5zwanzig ähm abends aller Voraussicht, nach wieder im Chaos-Radio zu Gast und ähm werde bei der Gelegenheit dann auch erzählen, was ich,
so angekündigt habe zu verbloggen und wonach ich weiß nicht fünfmal pro Woche,
App dot net oder Twitter gefragt werde, wie ich äh mein meine Computer sichere
Das wird also bei der Gelegenheit dann hoffentlich erzählt werden. Also wir wollen uns ein bisschen über äh verschlüsselte Kommunikation da unterhalten und wohl auch über das äh Sichern von,
Rechnern grundsätzlich sichern von Daten, die man in der, in der Cloud unterbringt und uns da auch so ein bisschen darüber austauschen, wie wir das äh untereinander machen. Ich bin da sehr gespannt drauf, weil ähm,
das auch nicht vollständig weiß, wie der Erdgeist das so macht und der Nibler, die auch da sein werden und ähm.
Schöner Nerd-Talk so. Ja, ich mache das ja so, ich mache das ja so, aber ey, meins.
Der kommt. Ich mache das ja so zweiunddreißig Zeichen-Fasswort reicht auch nicht aus.
Ich habe aber den größten Key.
Ich hatte längsten Key. Nee, ich will mal, ich hatte
Bin mal gespannt. Also, ich glaube, es wäre eine ganz interessante Sendung. Ich glaube, dass ich da eventuell ein paar interessante Sachen für Hörer erzählen kann, so aus meiner
aus meinen Ansätzen und bin mal, gehe sogar davon oder ich gehe hoffe, dass ich eventuell auch noch neue Sachen dann lerne,
wie man vielleicht andere Probleme angehen kann, die ich noch nicht und ich mich noch nicht so gekümmert habe.
Genau. Und wer noch so ein bisschen Gefühl für verhältnismäßigkeit bekommen möchte, dem empfehle ich mal sofern äh er oder sie in Berlin wohnen oder vielleicht, wenn ihr mal hier in Berlin Urlaub macht, kommt ihr auch mal vor so am Wochenende.
Da gibt's dann diesen schönen Neubau der Bundesnachrichtendienst Zentrale.
Und einfach mal nur um diese Baustelle herumzugehen und mal so Fenster zählen, das äh ist auch schon mal sehr erleuchtend, finde ich.
Weil das einfach mal,
Einfach mal so scheiße groß dieses Teil. Das ist einfach unfassbar. Man fragt sich eigentlich, was machen die da eigentlich den ganzen Tag?
Die Frage, mit der wir euch dann hier entlassen.
Können wir machen, ja?
Genau. Machen wir das jetzt auch. Wir sagen tschüss. Ciao ciao.
Tschau, tschau.